3,1 85,9 de 6 5 3 quels sont les dix
premières décimales du nombre pi défini
comme le rapport entre la circonférence
du cercle et son rayon divisé par deux
et voici maintenant à l'écran les 100
premières décimales
de ce nombre
ce que vous remarqué quelque chose est
ce que vous pourriez utiliser cette
suite de nombres pour prédire par
exemple le suivant cette liste d'après
vous quelle serait la 101e décimales de
pi et que pouvez-vous dire de la
googlienne décimales de pi c'est à dire
la 10 puissance 100e décimales de pi
à ce jour personne ne l'a calculé mais
alors quelle serait la probabilité que
cette googlienne décimales soit égal à 7
les décimales de pi sont troublantes car
bien que pi soit une constante
mathématique incroyablement simple
définir les décimales paraissent
incroyablement complexe voire aléatoire
comme on a d'ailleurs déjà parlé dans le
tout premier épisode de sainte flore
ça ne me rajeunit pas il ya même une
conjecture qui postule que le nombre pi
est un nombre normal ce qui voudrait
dire que les décimales son écuyer
répartis en un sens le set est alors
aussi fréquent dans les décimales de pi
que n'importe quel autre chiffre mais
alors il est tentant de dire que en
l'état actuel de nos connaissances la
probabilité que nous gaullienne
décimales de pi c'est à dire celle qui
se trouve 10 puissance sans chiffres
après la virgule
la probabilité que sept décibels est un
set est égal à 1 10e mais cette phrase
est elle juste est elle conforme au psg
à nice mme hess ce qu'on obtiendrait si
on appliquait la formule de bise
qu'en pensez vous
pour bien comprendre cette question il
est en fait crucial de faire la
différence entre le pur béziat nisme qui
consiste à respecter rigoureusement les
lois des probabilités et le pseudo
bayani sme qui consiste à imiter la pure
bayésienne sans toutefois appliquées
rigoureusement les lois des probabilités
en fait quand j'ai effectué des paribas
essien ou quand je vous invite à
répondre à des qcm bayésiens je ne vous
invite en fait pas à être purement
bayésiens je vous invite en fait à vous
inspirer du pur parisianisme pour donner
des réponses pseudo bayésienne et en
particulier quand j'affirme que la
gougouline décimale de pied est un set
avec probabilité un dixième je fais une
affirmation pseudo bayésienne clairement
je n'ai pas appliquer la formule de base
pour en arriver à cette conclusion
comme je le dis dans le premier épisode
de cette série je ne suis pas bayésiens
au sens où je n'applique pas la formule
de base tels que je devrais l'appliquer
et aujourd'hui on va voir l' argument
implacable qui m'a fait renoncer ou pure
paysanne isme il avance la revenons-en à
psa googlienne décimales que dirait la
pure bayésienne y at il un sens vraiment
bayésiens à dire que la google i am
décimales de pi est un set avec
probabilité 1/10 et bien la réponse est
non donc parce que pour la pure
bélizienne le nombre pi est tout à fait
déterminé pour elle
en effet il ne manque à la pure
bayésienne aucune information pour
déterminer la googlienne décimales de pi
ce nombre est parfaitement définis et il
lui suffit de faire un calcul par
exemple en ajoutant les deux google
premier terme de la somme infinie 4 mon
cap tiers +4/5 mon cas de septième plus
4/11 et ainsi de suite et retourner là
googlienne décimales du nombre ainsi
obtenu la pure bayésienne a ainsi toutes
les données nécessaires pour calculer
exactement 7 googlienne décimales anac
un simple calcul à exécuter pour y
arriver
mais comme on l'a vu un pur bayésienne
ne se met aucune contrainte de puissance
de calcul n'y a donc rien qui lui est
incertain dans les décimales de pi
pour bien comprendre la nuance
une sur pie et d'autres incertitudes
comme sur le futur de l'humanité par
exemple il faut prendre le temps de
distinguer l'incertitude par manque
d'information de l'incertitude par parra
scolytes yves je vais illustrer tout ça
avec un exemple historique au lendemain
de la seconde guerre mondiale en 1950 un
économiste et demanda aux statisticiens
david blackwell comment déterminer la
probabilité d'une autre guerre mondiale
dans les cinq années à venir
blackwell en bons élèves fréquentent
istres répondit alors au cette question
n'a aucun sens les probabilités
s'applique à de longues séquences
d'événements répétable or il s'agit là
clairement d'un cas unique
la probabilité est soit 0 soit 1 mais
nous ne serons pas avant cinq ans ce à
quoi l'économiste rétorqua j'avais peur
que vous disiez cela j'ai parlé à
plusieurs autres statisticiens et nous
tous des mêmes choses clairement et
statistiques fréquentes east était alors
très très dominante pour une bague et
viennent toutefois la probabilité d'une
guerre mondiale dans les cinq ans à
venir est une question qui a tout à fait
un sens il s'agit de mesurer la fraction
des branches du multivers bayésiens ou
une guerre nucléaire a lieu mais surtout
il est important de noter que
l'immensité de ce multi verbe haïtien
n'est pas dû à une paresse
intellectuelle
si en 1950 un pur bei viennent ne savait
pas s'il y aurait une guerre mondiale
dans les cinq ans à venir
ce n'est pas parce qu elle manqué
d'intelligence ou parce qu'elle faisait
preuve de paresse cognitive si elle
avait une incertitude sur le futur c'est
parce qu'elle manquait de données il est
donc crucial de voir que en pratique
en plus du manque de données nous autres
humains sommes aussi limité par la
puissance de calcul à laquelle nous
avons accès via nos cerveaux ou via nos
machines et bien sûr à ce jeu là la
paresse positive c'est-à-dire la paresse
à vouloir bien réfléchir et approximer
adéquat on la formule de bayes n'est pas
mais même si nous autres humains
faisons de notre mieux avec toute notre
puissance de calcul cognitive et
électroniques n'arriveront sans doute
pas à déterminer la googlienne décimales
de pi et ça ça vient d'une autre
propriété fondamentale du calcul le
calcul semble généralement irréductibles
telle est en tout cas la thèse de
l'irréductibilité algorithmique défendu
par stephen wolfram certains calculs et
même probablement l'écrasante majorité
des calculs ne peuvent pas être court
circuiter la seule façon d'obtenir le
résultat c'est de faire le calcul dans
son intégralité
taylor certains résultats de calcul peut
être même l'écrasante majorité des
calculs sont et
meuron à jamais inaccessible à nous
autres humains car la puissance de
calcul nécessaire pour les obtenir
sur passe très largement les limites
physiques de notre univers et elle
pourrait être le cas du calcul de la
googlemap décimales de pi pour prendre
d'autres exemples tel semble être
largement le cas de la résolution des
échecs ou du jeu de go comme on l'a vu
dans l'épisode sur le rasoir d'occam
trouver la stratégie optimale à ces jeux
est en fait très simple au sens de la
complexité de solomonoff comme pour pis
il existe des algorithmes très simple
qui résolvent les échecs et legault la
difficulté de ces jeux la raison pour
laquelle le pseudo bas et ziani sme est
très utile pour atteindre des
performances sur humaine à ces jeux
c'est le fait que les algorithmes qu'on
connaît et qui résolve ses jeux
nécessitent des calculs monumentaux pour
fournir les résultats nous dit que ses
algorithmes ont une énorme complexité en
temps de calcul
à ce sujet je me permet de relire cet
extrait fantastique dont l'un des plus
grands génies de l'histoire aux côtés de
solomonoff et la place la place à savoir
alan turing extraits que j'avais
d'ailleurs déjà lu dans une vidéo de la
série sur lire je cite l'idée que les
machines ne peuvent pas conduire à des
surprises est une conséquence je crois
d'un sophisme fallacieux auquel le
philosophe et mathématicien sont
particulièrement sujets il s'agit de
l'hypothèse selon laquelle dès qu'un
fait et présenter un esprit toutes les
conséquences de ce fait saute
immédiatement à l'esprit de celui ci
cette hypothèse est très utile dans
certains cas mais on oublie trop
facilement qu'elle peut être fausse
le sophisme que turing souligne là est
ce qu'on appelle le plus couramment le
sophisme de l'omniscience logique de
façon plus générale
sophisme consistent à soumettre les
limites calculatoire lorsqu'on réfléchit
à la connaissance c'est en tout cas le
point de vue que défend l'informaticien
scott aronson dans un article absolument
merveilleux intitulé pourquoi les
philosophes devrait s'intéresser à la
théorie de la complexité algorithmique
aronson explique entre autres que la
notion de plus grands nombres premiers
connu à ce jour n'a aucun sens si on
omet les contraintes algorithmique après
tout il est très facile de décrire
algorithmique mans un nombre premier
plus grands cependant aronson note que
en tenant compte des contraintes
algorithmique cette définition
parfaitement correcte paraît en fait
inadaptée car la mise en oeuvre de cette
définition nécessite plus de temps que
l'âge de l'univers
pour calculer le nombre en question ce
nombre premier plus grand que le plus
grands nombres premiers connu est alors
inconnu non pas car on ne sait pas le
décrire
mais parce que l'algorithme utilisé pour
le décrire est trop lent ce nombre
premier plus grand est connaissable mais
pour nous autres humains ou machine
n'est pas connaissable immédiatement il
en va de même pour la googlienne
décimales de pi 7 décimales peut être
décrite par un algorithme très simple
mais cet algorithme est horriblement
lent si cela ne pose aucun problème ou
témoins de ce n97 pur by then capable de
faire n'importe qu'elle calcule
instantanément
il s'agit en fait là d'une observation
rédhibitoire pour nous autres humains
machine d'un point de vue pragmatique du
coup cette décimales nous est inconnue
le problème le plus prestigieux de
l'informatique théorique formalise
justement lattès d'irréductibles it et
algorithmique et l'impossibilité de
l'omniscience logique en une conjecture
mathématiques bien défini ce problème
est appelé p versus mp en gros il s'agit
de déterminer si tous et puzzles peuvent
être résolus avec des algorithmes rapide
alors pour être précis par puzzle
j'entends un problème avec une réponse
facile à décrire et dont il est facile
de vérifier la validité
comme c'est le cas du sudoku en effet
présenter une solution un sudoku est
simple il suffit de remplir des cases et
pour vérifier que la solution est juste
il suffit de vérifier que chaque ligne
chaque colonne et chaque sou carey a
bien des chiffres entre 1 et 9 tous
différents cependant aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître à ce jour ne
dispose toujours pas des algorithmes
rapides pour résoudre le sudoku et je
pense là en particulier aux très grands
sudoku qui ne sont pas les neuf par neuf
plutôt et sudoku cesse par 16 et 25 par
25 cents par 100 voire dix mille par
10000 l'écrasante majorité des
informaticiens pense aujourd'hui que
paix est différent de np ce qui revient
à dire qu'il existait des puzzles comme
le sudoku qui ne peuvent pas être
résolus rapidement par un algorithme ou
dit autrement
de nombreux problèmes comme résoudre les
échecs ou casser les codes bancaires
semblent être fondamentalement
irréductible et ne pourront ainsi jamais
être pleinement résolus par des machines
ou des humains dans notre univers et
tout ça ça une conséquence majeure pour
le bdia nisme sachant que calculer la
formule de base en particulier est un
problème
np dur c'est à dire qui est plus dur que
résoudre des puzzles comme le sudoku le
fait que paix soit différent de np
combinée avec la thèse de complexité
algorithmique quantique de church turing
montrerait que la pure bayésienne ne
peut pas faire ses calculs dans notre
univers et ça c'est l'argument fatal
contre le bail à nice mme si vous voulez
rejeté le paysagisme en une phrase voici
ce qu'il vous suffit de dire les
probabilités ne peuvent pas être calculé
efficacement nous encore vous pouvez
dire pays' et nt dur ou dit plus
simplement le biz à nice mme requiert
des calculs déraisonnable ainsi même les
versions calculable de l'induction de
solomonoff sont déraisonnables en
pratique car pour les appliquer d'autres
univers surtout avec des gigaoctets de
données collectées l'âge de lune
vers ne suffirait absolument pas nous
sommes condamnés à être des pseudos
parisien
ceci dit de la même manière que tous les
modèles ne sont pas tous aussi utile ou
crédible tous les pseudos bézian ne se
valent pas certains se contentent de se
prétendre bayésiens d'autres sont juste
des tirs leader d'une théorie qui ne
comprennent pas vraiment les meilleurs
eux reconnaissent que le bail à nice mme
est un idéal inatteignable mais cherche
à s'en inspirer pour mieux l'approché
dans mon livre la formule du savoir pour
décrire cette troisième catégorie
je parle alors de bellezane isme
pragmatique de la même façon que les
joueurs et les algorithmes d'échec et
cdh approximer aussi bien que possible
les algorithmes optimaux des échecs
à défaut de pouvoir appliquer
rigoureusement les lois des probabilités
le boys and his mme pragmatique consiste
à identifier et à appliquer les
approximations assez juste et très
rapide à calculer de la formule de bise
en cela le pur benziane isme ont exploré
en long en large et en travers dans
cette série et qui est discutée dans le
premier tiers du livre
la formule du savoir reste une référence
importante
il s'agit d'un idéal simple et élégant
bien défini et au sujet duquel on peut
démontrer des théorèmes spectaculaires
comme la complétude de solomonoff il
s'agit surtout d'un calcul qu'il nous
faut approximer étant donné nos limites
en puissance de calcul et nos biais
cognitif d'ailleurs ou moins en
épistémologique comme l'a fait la place
en 1814
on peut définir des biais cognitifs
comme étant des divergences systématique
entre nos intuitions et les lois des
probabilités
ainsi depuis un bon demi siècle le pur
benziane isme inspiré de nombreux axes
de recherche de balises à nice mme
pragmatique sur lesquels on reviendra
dans de futurs vidéo malheureusement
contrairement aux purs balises yanis mme
qui se réduit aux lois des probabilités
le boys and his mme pragmatique est un
foutoir ou parce qu'on veut de
l'efficacité à hugo rythmique
on se doit de mélanger toutes sortes
d'astuces de calcul pour espérer
approcher le calcul des lois des
probabilités
néanmoins toutes les propositions de ce
foutoir ne se valent absolument pas
certaines sont bien plus à même
d'obtenir des résultats
approximativement cohérent avec les
calculs d'une pure bayésienne au moins
pour certains cas d'application voilà
qui rend le belize à nice mme
pragmatique affreusement complexe mais
c'est peut-être ça qui rend cet ex de
recherche si excitant